on espère bien que ça s'est accélère
parce qu'il reste encore nombre
d'amendements et nous souhaitons
vivement que la réforme soit votée d'ici
dimanche donc les dispositions adaptées
seront pris par le président le moment
venu voilà
souhaitons vivement c'est le débat
démocratique maintenant il faut que
chacun y mette du sien pour de façon à
ce que chaque prise de parole chaque
amendement amène une valeur ajoutée
qu'on ne s'est répétitive je ne suis pas
sûr que ce soit tout à fait
indispensable donc nous souhaitons
véritablement discuter d'amendement qui
sont une portée notamment dans le cas de
notre volonté de porter une meilleure
justice sociale au dispositif
on a entendu à travers cette
manifestation de
d'incompréhension à juste titre quand on
demande un effort collectif il faut
aussi qu'il soit justement partagé je
comprends tout ça mais on a entendu que
notamment les gens étaient sensibles à
l'effet de la prise en compte de l'usure
professionnelle prendre en compte
également ce que les carrières hachées
des maires de famille soient mieux
traités c'est la raison pour laquelle
ces dispositifs nous allons les aborder
et nous sommes vraiment impatients de
traduire
cette cette
volonté d'amélioration de la réforme à
travers un texte qui sera me semble-t-il
nettement plus acceptable que celui qui
a été proposé jusqu'à présent par le
gouvernement
je pensais pas que adopter le report de
l'âge légal ça risque de mettre en plus
d'huile sur le jeu bah écoutez fut un
temps où a été adopté l'allongement de
la durée de cotisation l'accélération de
la réforme c'est déjà dedans c'est juste
une accélération donc c'était bien une
volonté que faire en sorte que l'on
travaille plus longtemps quand le nombre
de cotisants diminue durée de retraite
augmente c'est incontournable le
décalage de l'âge pose plus sur ceux qui
ont commencé tard voyez-vous et en
conséquence faut des mesures pour
prendre en compte les notamment cette
usure supplémentaire arrivait à un
certain âge
non non c'est le gouvernement qui est
venu sur les propositions que nous
faisons depuis quatre ans mais si nous
avions présenté la loi nous aurions fait
une loi travail avant et nous aurions
pris davantage de mesure de justice
sociale donc ce que l'on souhaite
véritablement c'est que maintenant le
gouvernement fasse ce dernier petit bout
de chemin qui fera que ces réformes sera
quand même plus juste qu'elle n'est
aujourd'hui
[Musique]